if you want to test a real supercar you
need a super track and a super driver
former racing driver Klaus needs Fitz is
trying out the new audi r8 on a race
track in portugal toy yet skids so we're
going out on the porta mal racetrack he
says it's a fast and challenging circuit
and probably not easy for a car like
this let's see a show me man adesso says
he's going to switch off all the
electronic driving aids but that's hace
how it really feels like a racing car he
says feeling the performance data leave
no doubt that the audi r8 is a racing
car even if it is licensed for public
roads the engine produces a hefty 449
kilowatts of power and needs just 3.2
seconds to reach 100 km/h oh and it as a
top speed of 330 kilometers per hour
yeah mold off the engine responds
immediately Klaus says 560 newton meters
of torque is of course a lot it has a
seven-speed dual-clutch transmission
that is very fast and very precise South
Kadesh nel mondo Zappa teaser that's all
the link it steers much better than its
predecessor he says it feels a bit
softer feels generally a little comfier
but the car is still very fast all wheel
drive is of course another plus that
helps you to keep traction when you're
coming out of a bend so here you hit the
gas accelerate out of the curve and the
car keeps its course thanks to the
all-wheel-drive there's hardly any loss
of traction fantastic a real race car
how about this absolute pizza I hate as
an auto the r8 looks almost like a
carbon copy of its predecessor but it's
actually a completely redeveloped model
based on the Lamborghini hurricane the
few changes to the exterior are actually
a bit of a letdown the new r8 lacks some
of the exotic and Ronnie look of its
predecessor the new r8 is wider and
comes with a v10 plus engine making it
more powerful customers can choose
between the v10 with 397 kilowatts or
the one we tested with 449 kilowatts
both versions are equipped with a new
and improved faster 7-speed dual-clutch
transmission
here's all the way that this car will of
course not only be used on racetrack he
says most people will drive it on public
roads and I have to say it's totally
suitable for everyday driving out ace
made a few changes to ensure that the
tree away from the racetrack the r8
takes curves with a stability that is
almost disconcerting there is no
noticeable force outwards it speeds out
of the bend thanks to audi's quattro
technology the neue office new r8 is
really a completely new car he says a
lot lighter in weight many parts have
been made in the aluminum or carbon
fiber and this is how it looks the
existing aluminum spaceframe has had a
substantial amount of carbon added to it
the central tunnel rear wall and be
pillars are made from carbon fiber the
body shell is now fifteen percent
lighter and posts forty percent more
rigidity that means the new r8 ways
awful 50 kilos less than its predecessor
its curb weight 1555 kilos not bad for a
car with all-wheel drive and a ten
cylinder engine though the dial is their
fault and this is what the v10 engine
looks like he says it's a 5.2 liter
engine with 610 horsepower and a maximum
torque of 560 Newton meters what's
special is that the car is also designed
for the road and so howdy has installed
a cylinder on demand function at lower
torque and rev levels one of the two
cylinder banks is automatically switched
off which saves fuel so in the best-case
scenario that would mean a full
consumption of twelve point three liters
per 100 kilometers badalti 3ds motor
here in green section Fallon football
fan or 12 kamata later
but you have to be very restrained if
you want to keep to that level and
that's not easy because the r8 was born
to run at top speed
how they've been victim with the new re
can do he says it's a real toy to be
enjoyed but also good for anyone who
just wants to drive fast schnell out the
fan base